hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith and today we're getting
ready for this year's Oscars nominations
announcement with a behind the scenes
look at what happens on nominations day
we talked to several Academy insiders to
get the scoop on how the nominations
list is protected what goes on inside
the theater and how the hosts reveal the
names of the lucky nominees so let's
take a look inside the nominations
announcement it's my pleasure this
morning to unveil the nominees for the
66th of the 70th and 78th annual Academy
Awards I think overall the announcements
show is what all film fans are waiting
for and that is to see if their favorite
film was actually going to be recognized
by the Academy for Best Original
Screenplay the nominees are the whole
world sits in anticipation and you know
is curious about you know what those
nominations are gonna be do you know Tom
Hanks Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
crashed Paul Haggis the production of it
is basically an all-night affair we
begin to Saturday before by removing
seats in the theater so the press can
actually set up their camera crews so
that they can stand and do live
reporting live broadcasting the staff
it's working overnight begins at 9:00
p.m. the night before and goes all the
way until 5:30 in the morning
nominations night pricewaterhousecoopers
myself along with a couple other
individuals will show up and will hand
over a complete listing of the nominees
for that year I like the nomination is
more than the Oscars in a lot of ways
and the reason being is there's a
hundred plus winners it's fun
so once PwC delivers list of nominees to
us the Academy shuts down all forms of
communications the outside world it's
great because all of us are kind of on
the edge of our seats when we get the
list so you have this information and
you're just like busting at the seams oh
I saw that one that was really good oh
this is a shocker I can't tell anybody
the feeling in the room is intense we
have all of the press that's gathered in
the lobby it's like this ticking time
bomb of okay go it's literally a
stampede of press that comes up the
stairs and into the theater
it's basically packed to the brim and
it's buzzing at 5:30 morning typically
we have the president of the Academy
making the announcement morning
everybody
I'm Sid Ganis president of the Academy
and he or she is joined by an actor
actress Geena Davis Kathy Bates Forest
Whitaker Jacqueline
thank you Tom good morning everyone this
year Academy president show up when
Isaac's will be joined by actor Chris
Hemsworth you're a fan of movies I think
you're going to be excited by watching
the show itself it's always interesting
to see what was selected and what wasn't
I'm excited you know
we've got some amazing movies this year
and I'm really eager to see what what
the members have chosen congratulations
to all the nominees it'll be a night to
remember
see you then everybody
are you ready to find out this year's
nominees will tune in to Good Morning
America on January 16th to watch the
announcement live and go to Oxford calm
to see the full list of nominees and
look for more inside the Oscars updates
on Oscar com
thanks for watching